[Musique]
janvier 2022 après tous ces mois force
est à partager tous herpin famille
tenait déjeuner avec des légendes de la
vie parisienne c'est une vieille
tradition ancestrale ça fait 20 ans
qu'ils font ce déjeuner
c'est toujours agréable de louper le
début les retrouvailles des embrassades
le premier verre tu veux pas me raconter
ça leur voiture plutôt
à dieu paris un film qui s'adresse à
toutes les générations
vous aimez les intérêts le bonbon adieu
paris les mots d'esprit les plus fins
iata stoller jamais d'une cagoule
[Musique]
schéma pas confortable que nous te
présenter ici aujourd'hui après ce qui
s'est passé
adieu paris des plats raffinés et pluton
vinaigrette des conversations brillante
dont monop melco draper jon hamm bordel
adieu paris des gens qui s'aiment un peu
beaucoup il vient d'où ton pognon toile
il vient d'où il vient il vient d'être
avalé un bouffon c'est bien huilé des
gens qui savent se détester qui a été le
plus lamentable cette année mais non
mais non moi objectivement je ne
je n'ai ce que tu veux de l'aide peut-on
aller bien quand tout va mal a l'air
d'aller bien mais moi non plus je vais
pas bien qui va bien qu à cela ne va
bien ça va les nazes ça va secouer ça va
bonne ambiance
tu vois le dîner de cons oui eh ben si
vous voulez quoi adieu paris un film aux
préoccupations universelles mémoire le
sec je suis con moi j'ai prévenu moi je
le trouve encore très séduisant comme
c'est beau un homme à table un homme
face aux poteaux ce il a une tête de
danse un pot-au-feu me sens derrière
chaque pot-au-feu 4 carnage attend jeu
sécurisé le périmètre go go go
voilà c'est ça c'est ça qu'on veut c'est
ça qu'on veut ce moment de sa mort
[Musique]